views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
he cares about this almost as much as he
does florida new york we're taking
nothing for granted in nevada
and we benefit from the last few years
of real investing in the democratic
party infrastructure
[Music]
tonight on politics now with less than
100 days until the november election we
dig into the presidential race here in
nevada
plus i do think the board is divided and
it's unfortunate
ccsd superintendent dr jesus jarrah
keeps his job
the contentious board meeting that shows
just how divided trustees are
it's alarming because if this is
happening
what else is happening
[Music]
nevada's employment office is not
providing details on the fraud they say
is widespread
the i-team went digging for answers
[Music]
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
nevada's second special legislative
session is now underway
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler a second meeting of the nevada
legislature started on friday morning
the governor says this session will last
until next friday the 7th
on the agenda criminal and social
justice reform including use of force
and police liability voting in the
november election how will that go
forward
including in-person and polling
locations that'll be discussed
changing rules so people can get paid
unemployment benefits and evictions
all on the agenda another potentially
contentious measure
would address covet 19 liability
protections for schools
and businesses the general election
meanwhile is a hundred days away less
than that now
so with that in mind we wanted to dig
into some of the races
president donald trump held campaign
rallies in texas on wednesday
he touted his energy policy the
president has rolled back regulations
he's expanded export opportunities he
says and granted four pipeline permits
including one that he says will send
texas crude oil to mexico
as long as i'm pure president we will
never let anyone
put american energy out of business for
the first time
in nearly 70 years we have become a net
energy exporter
on the corona virus president trump says
there could be a vaccine by the end
of the year nevada republican party
chairman michael mcdonald
is the main surrogate for president
donald trump here in nevada
i spoke with him about the race we saw
an ad just go out from
vice president biden this morning i
believe it is i haven't heard a whole
lot from
mr biden recently how has
mr biden's campaign affected how
the trump campaign is trying to get its
own message out to the public
i think it's it's if you look at the you
know first of all it's nice to see joe
biden actually come out
uh at least we know who we're running
against with the vice
president but when you look at it it's
also where he stands uh you know his
commercials also show the contrast
between the president
who has built the greatest economy we've
ever known in
in the history of america and we're
going to do it again because of the
coronavirus so more importantly salon
order
you know where joe biden stands with
people it's been hard for president
trump to have uh his
his rallies he had a couple of them
obviously but uh circumstances making
that challenging
we know what's happening with the
convention as well what
how detrimental is that to
your efforts you know i think when you
look at it what we've built here
uh we have the the largest ground game
we've ever assembled in the in history
of the state of nevada
uh we're one-on-one with the honesty
we're one-on-one with the trump campaign
so we've been blessed to have in in our
state the messaging that's available to
go out we have the strong leadership
from the trump campaign and from the rnc
our chairwoman's been very very
supportive so what that allows us to do
is obviously
uh we love to have the big rallies i
mean that's something that the
president's
phenomenal at and he's great at there's
no one better but more importantly the
one-on-one context
you know we've had 1.5 million uh voter
contacts in this state
and we're growing why not incorporate or
try and get congress to go through some
police reforms now what's the
what's the holdout well you know i think
they're they're trying to work
hand-in-hand but also the democrats if
you give them an inch that you know
they want to do with policing all the
way around uh you see where some
democrats should say look we want to
defund the police
we want to move forward so there's no
balance where the minute the president
is able to start talking and working
with the police unions working with
police officers
and police sheriff situations and say
look we need to move forward on some
type of reform
the democrats immediately go right to we
need to defund the police so there has
to be some type of common ground they've
done it time and time again against this
president where
he tries to reach across the aisle and
gets beaten with the olive branch
how is the president going to make sure
that americans
don't get forced out of their houses
don't lose all their money don't lose
everything
uh and especially here in nevada where
we're kind of on a razor's edge right
now
very much so i'm glad you brought up we
practice uh we practiced the
mask uh i lost a friend a couple weeks
ago personally
very close friend of mine that passed
away from the chronovirus so it's taken
very seriously
uh when you look at it from where we're
sitting right now it's it's very
difficult because we've had such
corruption inside the
the funds that came in here with the
unemployment which was staggering
uh that the people came in and took
advantage of it uh for people that
really need it
when you look at what the president's
able to try to provide where we have
some type of
i hate to say stimulus but it is a
stimulus uh that's not under corruption
that's not under uh
examples where people take the money but
don't need it uh so
it's it's something where i know he
cares about nevada more
i i hate to say this but he cares about
this almost as much as he does florida
or new york
where he lives he's been very bullish
about nevada he loves nevada
all right so we have that full interview
with michael mcdonald available for you
at eightnewsnow.com
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden is expected to pick his choice for
vice president any day
now on tuesday an associated press
photographer caught this
image of the former vice president's
notes and they mentioned
california senator kamala harris with
lines like do not hold grudges and
great respect for her during a campaign
event this week
biden detailed how his economic recovery
plan would address
racial inequalities my bill back better
plan
would make sure families in these
communities are the ones who benefit
from the hundreds of billions of dollars
in federal investment
biden's plan would set aside 30 billion
dollars for a small business opportunity
fund
and it would help asian black latino and
native american business owners
the plan aims to have at least 15
percent of federal
contract spending on goods and services
with minority-owned firms
well the senior adviser to the biden
campaign here in nevada is state senator
ivana kinsella
i asked her about the campaign so far
speaking of
uh by former vice president biden um
where is he
i don't think he's been here since the
uh the the primary
or since the caucus i should say um are
you concerned about the attacks on on
where he's been and the allegations that
he is in hiding
so the vice president has taken medical
recommendations really seriously as to
the need to social distance to
quarantine and to
follow best medical practices so he's
largely been in his home in delaware and
has taken
regional trips but that doesn't mean
that he's stopped working hard in fact
the vice president has said that he has
been working harder now than he
uh than he did previously because he has
glued to his screen and making sure that
he's communicating with voters as much
as possible
so let's talk about the coronavirus pure
and simple
from the biden campaign's point of view
what is president trump doing wrong and
what would a
president biden do differently joe biden
has taken
a very public position he would have
treated this
very differently first he would have
never discarded the pandemic as
something that will just
magically disappear like president trump
did he wouldn't have allowed for there
to be such a decentralized response like
president trump has
joe biden would have ensured that from
day one there was leadership coming out
of the federal level so that states
weren't forced to fight against each
other for things like ppe
and forced to compete in a global market
for
equipment like ventilators and masks and
testing
supplies what we've seen at every step
of the pandemic is an
epic failure coming from the federal
government and what
joe biden would do differently is not
only based on his
policies but also on the way he would
make sure that americans felt like there
was leadership coming out of washington
that there was
a plan to not only answer the public
health crisis but the ensuing economic
crisis
and really give folks a sense of
leadership
i know that's not quantifiable but it
would make a tremendous difference at a
time when americans
across the country are feeling epic fear
and uncertainty
the issue of federal authorities in
several cities
sort of the way these protests certainly
not everywhere but in
in a couple of cities have manifested
themselves in
violence and some clashes would abide in
presidency support putting federal
agents in
cities to deal with protesters in these
manner in this matter
yeah thus far we've seen the biden
campaign stand up and say
not only is that unacceptable it's an
unnecessary response to what have been
peaceful protests and
we can use our neighbors in portland as
a prime example where
there have been protests of moms
protests of veterans
who have come to stand up for
what is a very very special moment in
our country to speak to
the deep racism that permeates all
aspects of
policy making but particularly in
policing and criminal justice
and you can watch the full interview we
had with state senator kinsella on eight
newsnow dot com
all right coming up next here on
politics now fraud in the unemployment
system i had to have had my
my social security number and knew where
i work
the i-team's vanessa murphy digs into
how much fraud we know about and
who's looking into it plus the now wife
of congressional candidate
dan rodimer has had the police called on
him twice back in 2018 we have the
details
next on
from el pollo loco welcome back
to politics now
clark county school superintendent dr
jesus jarrah is keeping his job
after a contentious board meeting this
week dr jarrah now says he wants to
focus on education
but as kristen drummond explains trustee
criticism over his performance
remains superintendent dr jesus jars
says he's here
and staying focused on students a
statement he's continually made despite
the recent drama with trustees
who remain at odds with one another that
this was
an unbelievably calculated move
i do think the board is divided and it's
unfortunate concerns following
wednesday's special meeting
trustee danielle ford questions how to
move forward following an abrupt
adjournment
she called for the meeting along with
trustees linda cavazos and linda young
to address
dr jarrah's leadership and possibly
firing him but
i'd like to make a motion to adjourn he
finished without a vote on dr
jarrah's contract and division among the
board so how do you
suggest you guys come together i don't
have an answer for that
uncertainty now about unifying the group
and it may not happen
soon since trustee ford tells me she
plans to continue pursuing the matter
this is not the end at some point you
beat a dead horse
and i think that it needs to be done
dr jarrah deciding not to comment on the
drama but focus on the district
he released this letter thursday and
writes i am not a politician
i am an educator the superintendent
addresses challenges
adversity and fighting for students a
viewpoint
trustees claim to share i think there's
going to have to be some
healing that's going to have to happen
here dr jarrah says the district will
succeed
if everyone comes together in the
newsroom kristen drummond
8 news now trustee ford says her focus
on the superintendent directly relates
to
students and to schools she says she
wants to hold him accountable
so the best serve the community we'll
follow that also as it moves forward
meanwhile a nevada judge has ordered
several thousand unemployed workers to
finally get their benefit checks
but still tens of thousands of others
are waiting now the ruling stems from a
lawsuit filed by out-of-work freelance
and gig workers against the state
for pandemic unemployment assistance in
the program called pua
dieter says dieter told the court rather
30 000
pua claims were pending twenty two
thousand of those
flagged as fraud state officials say
three thousand of those claims were
actually eligible and were ordered to
get paid on monday
as for everyone else the judge says he
wants to see more progress
the court continues to be concerned that
the progress however
under the circumstances that people find
themselves in
here in nevada are moving
too slowly so what happens next
a special investigator appointed by the
court will update the judge
on what progress has been made by dieter
in two weeks
now as you just heard in that lawsuit
unemployment fraud here in nevada
it is a major problem while many
nevadans really need that benefit money
right now
fraudsters in some cases are stealing it
dieter is releasing few details though
about this major problem so the items
vanessa murphy went looking for answers
my operations director opened the mail
and it was a
filed unemployment application
with my name on it this is the document
debbie ritchie received
she's the ceo of body spa group did you
ever file for unemployment this year
absolutely not
absolutely not it's my company she says
she didn't receive unemployment money
either
they had to have had my my social
security number and knew where i worked
she called the department of employment
training and rehabilitation
or deter to report fraud ring ring ring
ring she says she hasn't been able to
reach
anyone it's alarming because if this is
happening
what else is happening the i-team
reached out to dieter
and a spokeswoman said fraud can be
reported on the website
claims will be investigated by staff and
eater may or may not follow up to get
more information
richie's director of operations for the
salon group describes the website as
confusing
it's crazy i don't know what's happening
nothing's making sense anymore so how
many unemployment claims are believed to
be fraudulent
in a letter asking the u.s inspector
general for an investigation into deter
republican state leaders wrote that
dieter recently reported up to 185
000 possibly fraudulent jobless claims
costing the state millions of taxpayer
dollars
when the i-team asked eater and the
governor's office for more information
details were not provided so we reached
out to local communities
because while information is being
stolen from workers at private
businesses like ritchie's
public employee info is also being
stolen
clark county reports 203 employees
victimized
the city of las vegas reports 50
fraudulent claims
henderson reports 100 for march alone
north las vegas reports 74 and boulder
city
45. the i-team has also learned
information has been stolen
from at least 17 metro employees
it just seems like there's no control
anymore of anything
ritchie says she contacted the credit
bureaus and she's keeping a close eye
on her bank accounts number one concern
is to stay
safe but second with all the fraud going
on it's just you really got to pay
attention to what you get in the mail
vanessa murphy 8 news now
so there is a task force for covid 19
related
crimes like unemployment fraud but
sources told the i-team there is some
confusion among
agencies about who actually investigates
these claims for example
metro police has no access to deter
systems
their investigators have been provided
the number of fraudulent claims
we do know metro's digital forensic
investigators are working through dieter
with dieter
through to investigate metro employee
fraud but that's just metro
at 8 news now we do have some
information for you at watching at home
and how to prevent identity theft just
go over to eightnewsnow.com
next on politics now a new plan for
coronavirus
governor steve sissellak says he plans
to dump the phase approach
what he plans to unveil next week
instead
monday on good day las vegas you're
watching
politics now
let's take a look now at the race for
congressional district 3.
first this week we have learned that the
now wife of republican congressional
candidate dan rodimer
called police on him twice in 2018.
neither of the calls led to arrests or
charges against roedimer
the former professional wrestler is
running against democratic congresswoman
suzy lee for her congressional district
3 seat one of the calls
was a domestic violence accusation in a
police report metro police officers
said it seemed to be an argument months
later the woman involved sarah duffy
called 9-1-1 again to report rodimer had
stolen cash
jewelry and some guns my ex-boyfriend
entered my home
and stole about 200 000 worth of jewelry
how long ago um 30 minutes
okay were you home when this happened no
but he sent me
photographs okay what's his name daniel
rhodeimer
the police also recommended that she try
and solve the call
the second call civilly as well
rodimer's campaign called the first call
of verbal dispute and said the couple is
now happily married with a baby on the
way they already have
five children as for the second call
alleging a robbery
rohdeimer's campaign says no items ever
left the house
and they were just moved to a different
location again rodimer was not charged
at all the nevada democratic party sent
out a press release though calling the
911
disqualifying meanwhile republicans are
focusing on the husband of congresswoman
susie lee
he received a loan from the paycheck
protection program
lee and the rest of the nevada
congressional delegation lobbied to
reverse a rule
excluding gaming companies from getting
those loans
two weeks after that rule was reversed
full house resorts the company owned and
operated by lee's husband
got a 5.6 million dollar loan our
washington dc bureau correspondent
alexandra limon
asked lee if that was a conflict of
interest the fact of the matter
is there was some bureaucrat in
washington
who made a decision to exclude gaming
based on some 20 year old guidance
i was doing my job i was standing up for
the interests of my state
and i'll let you know that now we have
seen over 40
000 businesses in nevada uh taking care
of
over half a million employees so to me
uh there was no conflict of interest i
was doing my job
and the interest was in the interest of
my state
lee says she was not involved in the
company's decision to apply for that
loan or husband's company
or the small business administration's
decision to award it to them
changes to daca the program that lets
children brought into this country by
their parents
illegally but lets the country illegally
by their parents stay here that is daca
homeland security announced it is no
longer accepting new applications for
the program it is also making renewals
for one year instead of two each
application costs five hundred dollars
paul